when we were talking you and i about
politics a little while ago you said
something that i thought was very
interesting uh which was that generally
speaking like the
um the funnier candidate will prevail
when you're talking about something like
sadly that's one of my theories one of
your theories
uh and then you suggested something
really interesting to me which was like
where you
which was like you were thinking maybe
we should try and uh
now the dynamic of this particular
action now completely changed like in my
opinion joe
you know is uh heavily favored in the
polls now and we're in the midst of a
crisis and so like the
humor test like at this point everyone's
like screw that like i'd rather just
like return to sanity
um but there was a uh but
there was a suggestion you had that i
thought was really interesting you were
like maybe we should get some comedy
writers together to like write some
um some good scripts or lines for
uh whoever the democratic nominee like
uh you know
like uh like may end up being and i mean
obviously we're in a different moment
now but i thought that there was
something really powerful to like your
uh your general thinking on it um which
is that
at this point politicians are
communicators
um and there's like certain language
they use to communicate uh you know that
uh is hitting with certain groups of
americans like maybe less so for
for others but i was part of these
debates
uh judd and it was clear to me that that
some of the candidates definitely had
jokes that they'd rehearsed
but they they certainly had stuff that
they'd like practiced sure
and we do have these debates upcoming
between joe and donald trump
that um may be one of the only
uh set of events that could potentially
even change the dynamic of the race
meaningfully
i i think that
you know in america unfortunately
so much of it is entertainment and
people are taken in
by charisma sense of humor
attractiveness and a lot of the
presidents from the past that maybe
had you know we're not appealing to look
at or listen to but who happen to be
brilliant
uh maybe some of those people would not
be elected today you know there are a
lot of people who are
incredible at their jobs who are really
uh not
pleasant to talk to or or look at
they're not funny
but maybe they're just amazing at making
the the correct choices or thoughtful
difficult choices and if you look back i
i joke about this but i do think it's
true you tend to see that the slightly
more
entertaining or warmer candidate often
wins i i mean when al gore lost
i remember being pretty shocked because
when you watch the debates
you know george bush was terrible in
those in those debates
but he did have a certain charm about
him and the country was doing great at
that moment the economy was
he was very strong with competition i
remember that
and and it was almost like the the
country had
you know a clinton fatigue a scandal
fatigue
and they weren't factoring in the fact
that the country was operating
in in you know for our country uh
pretty well the economy was doing very
well it wasn't the moment to toss out
the democrats but
a bored country is seeking
entertainment and a friend and
and and and i think that that has
happened many times in our in our
history where
we're attracted to that and i think you
might say the same thing about donald
trump where
he's more of an aggressive insult comic
um
and people didn't pay attention to the
fact that he had ripped off a lot of
students that he didn't pay his bills
that he was uh you know awful to women
uh you know there were so many very
clear
signals to us that he was corrupt and
not empathetic
and a dangerous person but people bought
into
you know his bravado his entertainment
factor
and he had no record so it was easy for
him to say
hillary clinton is corrupt because he
hadn't held any
elected office he didn't have to come
through on any of his promises i think
if you look at what
what happened he he really didn't
accomplish
any of the things that he was talking
about
yeah what you're saying is spot on judd
and this is one of like the great
dynamics that i'm scratching my head
about
it to some level with concern which is
that it seems like politics and
entertainment have
uh have merged in at least in some
respects
and then if you have some larger than
life uh figure that
millions of americans in the case of
donald trump felt like they knew from
the apprentice and other things then
then
like he like overrode um
a lot of other like the rest of the
republican field and then it was him
against
hillary he seemed somehow more
entertaining and appealing and
like quote unquote authentic sure and in
the democratic field too there was
something that happened and i was the
beneficiary of this so it's
not a knock but like let's say you have
folks like steve bullock
governor of montana who makes a late
entrance into the race
or michael bennett senator from colorado
who like people didn't find particularly
like exciting or whatnot that uh that
they
got uh ignored and blown off more or
less
um and then if you have like the magical
asian man who wants to give everyone
money
and like who came from the internet then
like i became more of like a figure
in part because like i was more
interesting um
now that this is not something i'm i
think is necessarily like a
super positive in uh american
like politics you know like i happen to
think both steve bullock and michael
bennett
um deserved more attention than they got
from voters or from in you know
folks in in the know
and it's one reason why you have people
suggesting completely
seriously that you know the rock should
run for president
or like someone that we all know chucker
kanye well tucker carlson like you know
on
like on the republican side who is like
a commentator entertainer but at this
point
the things have kind of merged where if
you have like a very prominent public
persona then that actually is like a
massive
um value add in terms of your political
currency
absolutely and it's scary i mean we
don't quite understand the
kanye west's motivations you know there
are some people who
you know would read uh something into it
about
him wanting to split the vote uh
and then other people who think like no
the whole thing is just a
a manic episode and there is no logic
behind it or
or vision he's just having a meltdown
but regardless
they say in certain states when they did
some quick polling maybe he already had
two percent
or four percent and that's what's scary
about the idea of unqualified people
jumping in because clearly our country
has not been
discerning enough to say
i don't think being on the apprentice is
enough
to run the country i don't i don't think
having those bankruptcies and running
hotels makes this person
qualify and so we are scared when we
hear
trump's kids are going to run one day or
tucker carlson or or
you know or the rock where you think oh
no
i i want someone who really understands
how government works
i want somebody who who has a
you know a vision that i agree with i
don't want to just be somebody who's
popular now it's not impossible that a
famous person
can turn out to be a a wise thoughtful
good president it's but man it's that's
a the percentages of that are probably
still pretty scary pretty low and we see
it with donald trump now
his lack of experience means he doesn't
really understand
how to work government he doesn't know
how to get
masks made he doesn't know how to get
enough test tubes
so that you could do the testing and he
doesn't want to
he literally doesn't even want to find
out how to do it because
he is lazy he clearly has educational
issues he doesn't think well
and so he says let the governors handle
it because he can't manage a
gigantic bureaucracy and we need people
that
know how to do that you know what what's
tough judd is and i i generally agree
with uh with a lot of what you just said
i'm just so many americans have looked
up and been like man this stuff's not
been working for us and even when you
and i talked about like the good times
of when
al gore was running in 2000 and you made
the caveat which was right is like
like relatively speaking things were
were good um
at that point even though now yeah
compared to now but we also recognize
that like uh that there's been a lot
there been a lot of people left behind
even like the relatively good times
these bad times are
showing just how exposed many american
families are where
you know like that like that there's
like uh uh just financial insecurity
everywhere and like uh and many
americans have felt excluded from
uh even the gains that have been made uh
and there's so many americans that just
look up and be like man
like even under the democrats like you
know my
factory was closing my main street
stores were closing because of amazon
like they look up and they're like not
sure in my opinion that's what one of
the things that fuels
like our interest in these folks from
outside government because like like the
the because people have
lost faith in a lot of things in our
society
um but but like one of the things
they've lost faith in is that if they
get
uh like the other party into
power in dc that things will
meaningfully change where
like in their school or on their street
or you know these things
now all of that said i'm obviously very
pro-biden i've endorsed him i've been
doing everything i can to help and i get
the sense from what you've just said
that you are also pulling for
uh team joe the fall
i don't think that's like much of a
stretch um so i would would love to
hear like uh what you're seeing
and also if there are particular races
that you're
um like focused on outside of the big
gahuna
race between joe and donald trump
whether there are some political
candidates that have caught your eye
um certainly on our side there are you
know um
a number of candidates that i'm trying
to help and elevate like at the local
levels
um and was wondering if if there were uh
people that you were working with on
that side
well i think that um you know
it's very important that the democrats
will win the senate
because
i think you know if you're to envision
what the next four years would be if
if joe biden was the president
we're going to be in the midst of the
pandemic into next year
maybe beyond into 22.
it also might be something that is
around in some form
chronically where it's like
the flu in the sense that we're getting
shots every year and what if the shot
only works 50
of the time i mean the flu shot we all
get it and some years we're like oh they
didn't get the right one this year
so we don't know how many years we're
going to be dealing with this where it's
very
serious hopefully there'll be some sort
of you know
medicines that help us even if we do get
it where it's not as dangerous
we don't know yet but that could play
out over years yes
so we we have to also assume that
that the country will be very impatient
for solutions from the next
president economic solutions for the
disaster that's
clearly coming from all of this
and also the medical issues and
if something really meaningful does not
happen
then joe biden will be a one-term
president
there's a chance he's a one-term
president anyway
maybe another democrat will run after
four years
and so without the senate um
i don't think he'll be able to make
large-scale
meaningful change in the country and be
able to fix a lot of what
we've learned about how badly our
institutions work
i mean we're basically finding out on a
daily basis that on almost any
issue you could take it to the supreme
court it takes
years and you don't actually get
solutions
you can't even find out if you're
allowed to
if the congress is allowed to subpoena
people to speak to committees
right we're we're still not sure if
they're allowed to
force people to answer questions to be
held accountable for their work
for the country uh and you could kick
the the can down
uh the street on almost anything in the
course right so the justice system is is
a complete mess the courts are a
complete mess and
my concern is that
if things don't turn around and it goes
right back to the republicans in four
years
and what it will be is a smarter donald
trump
a less demented donald trump
with the same long-term
vision i mean donald trump is not a very
efficient
person we don't know what we don't even
know how much of these
choices he makes are his or just the
people around him who are able to get
ideas through this strange man
you know when i hear that like they're
not going to let they try to not let
students stay in the country
if their college switches to zoom
classes
i don't think donald trump was in a room
and thought that up
you know that's that is the thing that
many people are concerned about judd is
like
imagine competent and malevolent uh you
know as opposed to
yeah and tom cotton you know you know
there's all these people
uh that are are truly dangerous that it
could swing back to them
very quickly if the country is still
struggling in a few years and you know
what the country will be
struggling and and so what what can a
president who controls the congress and
the senate do in terms of
of health care in terms of
you know larger changes thank you for
listening in i hope you enjoyed this
conversation
if you did please do subscribe to yang
speaks and click on notifications so we
can let you know
every time we have a new episode
[Music]
you